trying his best to salvage what the
sludge has not swept away this man is
one of thousands across Lavinia who woke
up to what the government describes as
catastrophic Devastation
the water penetrated around three or
four am it was destroying everything in
its way Workshop yard cars all of it
destroyed it nothing was left
some more everything was in the water I
took my car keys put the car in Reverse
my wife got in and that's how he got out
everything else was flooded
in 24 hours More Than A month's amount
of rain poured down officials are
warning of more flooding because rivers
are quickly swelling up
slovenia's environmental agency has
raised the weather alert to the highest
level prime minister Robert golub thinks
the floods could be the biggest since
Slovenia became independent in 1991. and
officials in many affected towns agree
this is
very quickly it was appearance that this
would not be a typical flood event that
it will not just be some flooded
basements one of the worst things is the
landslides in Loch Nitza that cut off a
big part of the village of Sora
Rescuers are having a tough time
reaching stranded people in the northern
and western parts of the country railway
lines have been cut off and power
outages are widespread Emergency
Services have made a public call for
rubber boats in places where roads are
impossible
through a state of emergency has been
declared the Army is standing by to help
the defense Ministry has our citizens in
those zones to stay indoors
everyone who does not have an emergency
route stay where you are any presence on
the road makes the work of rescue teams
even more difficult
meteorologists are expecting heavy rains
to continue for at least another 24
hours and to spread to neighboring
Croatia and Bosnia and further south